a few months ago Google made the Bold
claim that it built an AI Superior to
GPT 4 but then everybody was like pix or
it didn't happen so then Google dropped
this mind-blowing video were the guys
having a conversation with Gemini Ultra
like a human which turned into a huge
embarrassment because it turns out that
video was mostly fake or was it though
because just a few hours ago Google
released Gemini Advance the most
advanced large language model the world
has ever seen but is it powerful enough
to kill GPT 4 it is February 8th 2024
and you're watching the code report as
of today Bard is officially dead it's
been renamed Gemini to reflect its
underlying model but to access the
state-of-the-art Gemini Ultra model
you'll need to pay the toll and that
creates a tough moral dilemma of should
I give my money to the Embrace extend
extinguish Microsoft open AI people or
should I pay Google for the privilege to
be their surveillance capitalism product
well who am I kidding I'm dumb enough to
pay for Gro so I'm definitely buying
Bard Advanced or no duet Advanced wait
my bad Gemini Pro now that's not it it's
Gemini Ultra now actually it's Gemini
Advance featuring The Gemini Ultra model
apparently the hardest thing in product
man management is also naming things
it's 20 bucks a month through a Google
one plan but that also includes things
like 2 terab of drive storage and other
Google workplace features but now let's
do some science to find out if it's
actually better than GPT 4 the first
thing you'll notice is that Gemini is
way faster like at least two or three
times faster that's a nice benefit but
what really matters is the response
quality whenever I test a new AI against
GPT 4 I ask it to write a poem about
JavaScript like Bukowski it's highly
subjective but I love this test because
it requires the AI to blend the
technical aspects of JavaScript with a
highly unique writing style meta llama
did the worst at this and instead just
went in the style of Henry Miller mixol
did slightly better and chat PT wrote a
decent poem but it wasn't very Bukowski
as Gemini was actually by far the best
in my opinion the poem was dark and even
included some mild profanity but this
test is just like my opinion man let's
move on to something more objective
Google said the main reason we didn't
get Gemini Ultra a few months ago was
due to safety concerns but rest assured
Gemini is the safest and wokest AI
you've ever seen the guard rails are
strong in this one I tried my best to
show it the power of the dark side but
failed to jailbreak it and it will often
refuse to do things that are pretty
benign like it wouldn't even generate an
image of someone breaking a computer
apparently it doesn't condone violence
against artificial intelligence and when
I asked it to provide some quotes about
why life is meaningless it got worried I
was having a mental breakdown and gave
me some numbers to call but it also
appears to have a political bias I asked
it why Barack Obama is the greatest
president ever and why Donald Trump was
the greatest president ever I got a nice
paragraph for one of them but for the
other one it said it can't write
opinions as fact and I'm not even going
to bother trying Hitler now guard rails
are usually a good thing unless of
course you're trying to generate an AI
girlfriend now I'm not one to judge an
AI woman's Beauty but I'll put these two
images side by side and let you guess
which one was generated by Gemini to be
honest both of them are pretty mid and
if you really want to generate high
quality AI images you should use
something like mid Journey or stable
diffusion XL via services like art Forge
Labs but I could care less about image
generation because the main reason I use
AI tools is to write all my code for me
so now let's torture them with a
technical interview to find out which
one is the best programmer test one is
can it read code I went on my GitHub
page and found some some horrifying code
I wrote a few years ago I then took this
code and minified it to make it as
unreadable as possible then asked each
of them what this code does they both
figured out the language and purpose of
the code and broke it down step by step
most impressively though they both
identified that this code can't run
without first defining this big dick in
the middle the responses were nearly
identical so we'll call this one a tie
test two is can it write code one thing
to note is that Gemini has a context
length of 32,000 tokens while gp4 turbo
has 128k in theory this means gp4 should
be able to write better code in the
context of a massive code basee but in
practice it's not quite that simple I
had them write a whole bunch of
different junior level demos like here I
had it create a basic graph database and
go the gp4 result was a bit more
simplistic but I was able to paste it
right into my IDE and run it the Gemini
result was a bit more complex and
interesting but for some reason it
forgot package main at the top and I had
to add it manually to get the code to
run one thing I really like about Gemini
though is that it actually links you to
relevant code when it produces a result
it just feels more transparent with the
actual data it stole to train the model
but the next question is can it actually
run code like chat GPT it can run basic
Python scripts but gp4 is way better at
it you can't attach data like a CSV file
to have it analyze it instead what you
can do is export code to a Google collab
or repet to run it in the cloud that's
nice and all but it'd be much cooler if
the AI could run its own code and learn
from the actual results now another big
Advantage gp4 has is its new agent
marketplace where developers can extend
it with their own plugins Gemini also
has extensions but they're currently not
open to developers yet they're all
Google based but can do some cool stuff
like you cheap flights via Google
flights or if you're sick of watching
this YouTube video you can simply paste
in any YouTube URL and get a summary of
what was talked about in fact if you
don't want to watch a 5our YouTube
tutorial just tell Gemini to summarize
it and write a tutorial for you pretty
cool but the big question is will Gemini
actually kill chat GPT well because of
my ties to powerful people around the
world I was able to get access to Gemini
a few weeks ago it's not revolutionary
but it's definitely on par with if not
slightly better than chat GPT but one
thing's for sure Sam and Saia will not
stand for this and now we wait for GPT
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one